the video I did recently I'll talk about
the two different alcoholics you've got
the one that suppresses a problem and
then you've got the one that alcohol is
a chemical problem the craving mechanism
people talk about oh I've opened the
floodgates now yeah yeah I needed 100
because my craving kicked in and I
couldn't stop that craving recruitment
probably exposed my insecurities and
frailties and now coal would be
something that I would use perhaps to
stop my brain stop my insecurities stop
my anxieties it started to kind of
suppress some of those things and hide
some of those things but also it
contributed to some of those things
because the thing with alcohol is
actually when you have alcohol your
depression goes up your anxiety goes up
your insecurities do go up they might go
for a minute but they come back a lot
worse I always had this vision of who I
was I'm going to be successful I'm going
to be entrepreneurial but with the
alcohol I was going the other way I was
turning into the liability I was turning
into the lunatic that everyone didn't
want to go out with and I think that was
the point to answer your question when I
suddenly went this is [__] up and you
know what the person that I want to be I
don't think I'm there yeah I'm not
saying I'm this cool yeah yeah I'm on
that Journey yeah I'm on that Journey